do you even remember this guy Evan
McMullen was the nevertrump errs last
hail-mary candidate remember he got gobs
of media attention despite the fact that
he never stood a chance of defeating
Trump back in the spring of 2016 well
for 2020 they found a new Savior radio
host Joe Walsh I'm gonna hit Donald
Trump I'm gonna punch him in the face
every single day
I'm running because he's unfit somebody
needs to step up and there needs to be
an alternative what an inspiring message
that's right
former Illinois congressman Joe Walsh is
who the never Trump movement if he can
call it that has been waiting for as
long as you ignore that he called Obama
a Muslim used the n-word on Twitter and
may have owed his wife a mere 117
thousand dollars in child support but
don't worry
Walsh is self-aware or is it I wouldn't
call myself a racist but I would say
John I've said racist things on Twitter
there's no doubt about it
whoops but none of that matters it
doesn't matter to the anti-trump forces
in the media because they are still
desperately hyping the impossible hood a
combination of a Joe Walsh and a bill
weld and maybe something else ding him a
little bit in maybe a New Hampshire
primary for example sure could they
cause problems for the president could
they weaken him going into the fall
certainly no matter how small they are
and whether they can beat you or not it
becomes a real irritant and it becomes a
problem no incumbent wants to have that
good lollipops grow on trees could the
road be paved with gold yeah yeah ok
wait none of you are convinced yet well
CNN's Chris ELISA has got your back Joe
Walsh he says could make some real
trouble for Donald Trump he writes
reality check
according to
Trump's approval rating sits at 88%
among Republicans that's just two points
fewer than george w bush right after
9/11
now the ringleader of this ill-fated
mission as I said earlier never Trump ur
Bill Kristol he's all in on Jill Walsh
telling the New York Times he has a
different appeal than bill weld the fact
that he was a tea party congressman who
voted for Trump in 2016
gives them an ability to speak to
Republican primary voters that never
Trump errs like me don't have hey Bill
you probably would have a better shot
with this joe walsh from the eagles now
what all the hype about Walsh is really
showing is just how pathetic and
self-serving the never Trump errs are
because just let yourself marinate in
this for a second
these folks are willing to sacrifice
their own country to say see I told you
so so they'll lose the Supreme Court all
the federal courts the economy the
gradually an upper hand with China all
of it they'll lose it all so they can
have their little moment and of course
they want to take us back to what the
days of endless foreign adventures big
government losing the culture wars open
borders etc etc etc anti-trump grifters
are completely out of touch with reality
they're kind of like the party of the
tooth fairy except there's no money
under your pillow in the morning just
more disappointment because another
Trump victory is coming and that's the
angle